Audrey is in Virginia
hi Audrey welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thank you so much for
taking my call I'm gonna try to get this
question out I'm super nervous but um
the reason I'm calling is that six
months ago my dad hired me to work for
his company my mom and my dad want my
husband and I to take over the company
in about three to four years when they
become full-time missionaries but I want
the company to be debt-free before we do
that
my parents have almost 75,000 of
personal and business-related debt and
my mom's the sole owner of the escort
company and she takes pay from the
company every month but she doesn't work
for the company or have a job and my dad
is an employee of the company and gets a
salary and when I do the projection my
mom not contributing to the company I
believe hinders the company's growth and
their ability to pay off debt before we
take over the company and I just wanted
to get your advice on how to handle the
situation how many team members and
there are one two three four team
members okay and you and your husband
are two of them and your dad is another
one sorry
no on my husband actually is not working
for the company at the moment my dad I'm
another employee myself and then I
actually included my mom and that as
well what do you what does the company
do I'm insurance restoration so I'm
general contracting okay how long has
your dad done that um he's been in the
business for probably over 20 to 30
years but this specific business that
he's open they just reopened this about
a year or two ago and you've been there
how long I've only been here six for six
months okay mm-hmm well there's a good a
couple of things to remember there are
there's an old thing that John Ward who
was one of the original writers about
family business back in the 50s he does
a Venn diagram of the three circles
overlapping kind of think like you know
that
the Olympic circle is kind of thing
right the three circles are flapping and
the three circles are owner family and
leadership okay
and you can be you can be all three of
those you could be a family member
that's an owner and be in leadership and
you'd be right in the center of all
three of those where they all three
overlap you see what I'm saying hmm but
you can be a leader that's not an owner
or a family member you could be a family
member that's not an owner or a leader
that'd be your mother okay
she's an owner but she's not in the
leadership and she's in family and so
there's two types of pay that come out
of any family business
there's the pay that goes to the owners
of the business which is the profits
after everyone has been paid okay
and they could be cept that can be
separated among the owners then and then
the people inside the business get paid
for the jobs that they do mm-hmm okay
and so your mom should not be taking a
salary out of this business under any
circumstances she should be given this
distributions she and your dad as the
owners distributions from the business
after it makes a profit after having
paid its employees your dad is an
employee you're an employee mm-hmm okay
so after the employees are paid if there
is a profit that is not your money
that's their money and that could go out
to your mom and dad and that could be
and should be in this case you used to
get rid of this debt if they want to
hand you the keys okay and so we've got
to reset this because you don't put
people on payroll who don't work there
yeah that's just weird all right
and people do it all the time in family
businesses but they do a lot of weird
stuff in family businesses that's just
wrong and you pay people not because
they're family that work there you pay
them for the job that they do for
instance what is your title hmm I'm the
office manager okay you would get paid
not for being the daughter you get paid
for being or the future owner you get
paid for being the office manager
if you could not hire another office
manager for that same amount that
they're paying you then you're not paid
enough or if they're paying you so much
that if you hired another office manager
at that rate they think they'd be hit
the lottery then you're being paid too
much yeah
follow me so that the rolls are paid
appropriately your dad is the CEO he's
the you know CEO CEO oh all of those
things he's running the business as the
president of the company and he should
be paid appropriately for that before
there are any profits yes so the
president doesn't work for nothing
because they're an owner yeah okay so if
you set if you separate all that stuff
out as if they're not family members and
pay people based on the the role that
they're in whether they're an owner or
whether they're a leader or whether
they're a family member family members
do not get money in family business yeah
only owners do and only people that work
in the business get paid on payroll so
that if you once you have that kind of
discussion with your dad then he can go
home and break it to your mom you don't
need to be the bad girl in this yeah I
think that's where I have the problem is
separating yeah your dad you and your
dad need to come to a clearer
understanding of how this thing needs to
be run until it's handed off to you and
then he needs to go home and explain
this to his wife yes I'm not not Audrey
came in and his throwing her weight
around as the office manager that
doesn't work yeah because you'll hear
your mom oh you're here your mom with a
mom voice in a minute and you can't use
your mom voice at business that's not
allowed no and you can't use your whiny
daughter voice at business either that's
not allowed exactly this is a
professional discussion by people
running a business about a professional
succession plan and so that's how the
people that's how the Ramseys that are
involved in this business are not
involved in this business get paid
Sharon Ramsey gets zero money out of
this company except for the fact that
she and I are the owners and when the
owners take some money home she and I
are the owners okay she does not get any
kind of paycheck from his company nor
has she ever for 30 years
that's just toxic you know once you lay
all that out then you can decide all
right dad
now we're running a business
professionally I don't really want this
business if it's got debt and you know
we got $75,000 to clear off here in
three years before y'all leave that's
$25,000 a year we got to take off before
you all start taking money home yeah we
gotta lay out a budget for debt
reduction and do some projections yeah
and I've done the projections and they
could actually probably pay it off in a
year yeah
if they could taking it all home but can
they eat if they do that yeah yeah
absolutely paying himself a salary yeah
he has a salary and then my mom gets
member dreyes yeah but can they live on
the salary yes they can't absolutely
they can live on his salary I would
rather everything else in the profits
towards the debt because the debt being
gone is a precursor to this succession
plan working yeah I agree
yeah that sounds great and it's not you
know you're you're not taking the money
from your mother your mother is merely
paying the debt off that she ran up yeah
as an owner that that's what I've been
thinking and I've been discussing with
my dad too so I just gotta get this
couch right in your head that somehow
you're not trying to create a situation
where you're somehow benefiting from
this because this local company doesn't
have a ton of value no you're basically
taking over a concept and a customer
list yeah exactly
it's not like you're getting a hand in a
20 million dollar company or something
here there's more employees and your
general contractor so you outsource all
of your labor just about yes absolutely
all of it and so you know if you know
there's not a ton of value in terms of
the actual value of the sub s here so
that's how you work it out and you can
do a lot of reading on family business
there's some wonderful stuff around on
it I've been studying it for about 15
years I think it's probably the next
book I'm gonna do because we're in the
middle of it I mean we've had family in
this business my the Remzi kids that are
adults you know are all in major roles
inside this organization and have
gravitated to those roles based on their
competency and their performance not
based on the
named over the last decade or so and
there'll be a day that they'll be
running this place and I'll be working
here
won't that be interesting it'll be
awkward as Kurt is one of them
but that's part of what you deal with